>> Genomics is the study of all the hereditary material,
or DNA, that makes up who you are. Now, until about
a decade ago, it wasn't even possible to look at
your whole genome at one time. We were only looking at
bits and pieces of your genome, regions we called genes,
individually, in a field called genetics. And eventually over time the
field of genetics, looking at these individual genes one at
a time blossomed into this field of genomics. Now the global
picture of genomics is to get a global picture of
you. Looking at many genes at one time to see
how they shape who you are. Obviously, this is a
pretty big task and we could use a little bit
of help. We've teamed up with 23andMe, a personal genetics
company based in California that aims to connect people with
their own genomes. I'd like to introduce to all of
you the Senior Director of Research at 23andMe, Joanna Mountain.
>> Thank you, Matt. I'm really excited to be part of Tales from the Genome.
>> Well, we're pretty excited to have you here. I'm curious, is there any
trait about yourself that you've always wondered
more about what the genetic cause is?
>> I have to say, I was always curious
about why I had red hair and freckles and no
one else in my family did. And where did
that come from? Yeah, how did I get so lucky?
[LAUGH]
And so that's something that I was curious about for much of my
life. And when I was able to look into my DNA, I could
start to learn more about who I might have inherited that from, and,
and what the genetic basis was for, for that red hair and freckling.
>> Now I'm sure some of you out there
have wondered about your own traits, so tell us.
What's one trait about yourself that you've always wanted
to know a bit more about the genetic basis for?